[Música]
eu sempre achei magnífico aquela
pergunta o que você quer ser quando você
crescer e eu acho lindo porque a criança
ela tem uma pureza - em uma simples
cidade maravilhosa e quanto mais a gente
cresce a gente vai perdendo isso a
criança tem o desejo de mudar o mundo
transformar vidas salvar as pessoas
tanto que quando a gente é criança a
gente quer ser astronauta gente que é é
ser médico a gente quer ser policial a
gente quer ajudar a gente quer mover o
mundo mas a gente vai crescendo e isso
vai mudando um pouco na gente
a gente vai ficando chato o pensamento
já não é mais mudar o mundo não é ajudar
as pessoas e ganhar dinheiro
não que ganhar dinheiro seja um problema
é natural mas a gente quer simplesmente
ganhar dinheiro eu acho que isso reflete
muito nessa sociedade que a gente está
vivendo em uma sociedade doente onde as
pessoas vivem na meio mediocridade das
pessoas elas não fazem o que elas gostam
eu comecei a perceber isso no caminho
para a faculdade
não vou contar um pouco da minha
história e todas as vezes que eu pegava
o ônibus eu percebia que as pessoas não
gostavam de estar ali as pessoas irão
trabalhar em algo que elas não gostavam
e aos torciam para que esse trabalho
acabasse logo a hora boa era hora de ir
embora
as pessoas iam para a faculdade elas não
tinham desejo nenhum detalhe elas faziam
coisas apenas para chegar na média e
passar e depois que você forma você nem
lembro que estudou para ser mais um
profissional medíocre que faz algo que
não gosta e infeliz
isso começou a mexer comigo porque como
muitos eu escolhi um curso e da minha
família esperava muito que o formou se
na faculdade eu sempre gostei de
escrever meu sonho sempre foi ser
escritor
eu decidi seguir jornalismo que pra mim
era o que estava mais próximo da minha
realidade
aos poucos eu fui percebendo que isso
não era o que eu gostava eu fazia o
curso e ele não mexia comigo não
empolgava e eu tentei primeiro período
segundo período terceiro período o
quarto período e foi aí que eu tomei uma
decisão que mudou minha vida pra sempre
eu tinha duas escolhas ou eu continuo
lá vem um curso onde eu não gostava mas
pelo menos eu teria um curso superior ou
eu largaria aquilo ali e tentaria mudar
a minha vida nesses próximos dois anos
que seria a conclusão do curso
lógico que a maioria das pessoas
pensariam é muito mais fácil você
terminar pelo menos ele vai ter um curso
superior e na pior das hipóteses e tem
uma cela especial
certo as pessoas pensariam assim eu
decidi mudar minha vida eu falei em dois
anos
isso vai isso vai mudar e fui conversar
com minha mãe já tinha algumas outras
coisas que geravam problemas na minha
casa e após uma discussão falei coisas
que não devia falou coisas que não devia
decide sair de casa
decidi morar sozinho e ver um primo meu
de montes claros também eles tinham
largado um curso a gente decidiu morar
junto e um dia fazer um brainstorm eu
era estagiário da prefeitura ganhava
r$420 isso não dava para sustentar uma
casa e falei com meu primo chamado
juntos vão fazer junto a gente precisa
pensar formas de ganhar dinheiro ea
gente fez aquele brainstorm eu sou fã de
brainstorm vai falar um monte de merda
até que uma hora sai uma coisa que
presta e os juros é um cara muito
inteligente e ele sempre teve idéias
ótimas mas ele não sabia como executar
essas idéias e do nada ele falou assim
olha um amigo meu falou da gente vem de
poesia eu falei cara que genial isso
vamos vender poesia né eu sempre escrevi
ele sempre escreveu ea gente sempre teve
essa vergonha de mostrar para as pessoas
a gente nunca quem escreve eu quem faz
alguma coisa na área de arte sabe como é
difícil mostrar algo que é de você algo
que é da sua alma algo que te torna
vulnerável ele falou isso achei genial
porque eu não conhecia ninguém tinha
vendido poesia eu falei ótimo jutsum
como que a gente vai fazer isso ele olha
eu pensei que a gente vai montar um
varal na praça sete
vai depender algumas coisas escrita à
mão e vão vender 15 reais e eu sou um
cara que a pessoa vai falando ou
imaginando ele falando eu já me imaginei
se na praça sete de dredd parceria na
perna fumando um torpedo sente assim não
é e eu não quero virar riff detran
seguinte vamos vamos pensar em outra
forma não sei
acabou que a ideia ficou lhe eu entrei
dentro do metrô naquele dia
e pela primeira vez eu reparei uma
galera que era muda entregava os papéis
eram a 4 dobrado no meio e eu cheguei
com essa idéia em casa foi em julho
vamos vender poesia igual surdo e mudo
lá no metrô
eu acho que ele não boto muita fé nisso
eu liguei para um amigo meu que faz
grafite comigo fala se em cask é lançar
um novo empreendimento aí está ligada e
precisa que se cola comigo vou te vou
dividir tudo conseguiu ganhar
e nessa época não existia essas empresas
e existia mas era tão famosas empresas
de pirâmide é que seja uma pessoa já
fica todo assim eu chamei ele foi e a
gente entrou no metrô em imprimir 200
folhas e entreguei para as pessoas
chegam aos 200 pessoas no vagão de metrô
eu entreguei e pela primeira vez eu me
apaixonei por uma profissão e isso era
muito especial para mim porque todo
mundo sempre falou da dificuldade de ser
ouvido
netinho assim de ser lido eu falei sim
eu nunca vou conseguir chegar a um
público grande com algo que eu escrevo
eu sempre me vitimizem muito e achei que
eu não era capaz e pela primeira vez
houve 200 pessoas lendo algo que eu
tinha feito isso foi muito especial pra
mim e eu me apaixonei por isso eu falei
faz diferença e aí eu fui é fiz aquele
discurso gente eu podia tá roubando já
está matando a estou aqui é veneno minha
poesia gente assim era 50 centavos ea
gente foi recolhendo e isso mexeu comigo
porque eu passava para recolher
ninguém me dava 50 centavos a mulher de
um real o time deu dois se viam que me
deu desde o quase pedindo em casamento
na hora falei caramba que louco isso
chega em casa animado júdson junto com
isso faz fé a gente vai ficar rico jogam
com as calças caindo cheio de moeda ea
gente não tinha nada a gente mobiliza a
nossa casa na época o dia das poesias e
foi um tempo maravilhoso
só que esse tempo durou pouco porque
vender coisa no metrô é proibido ea
gente teve que saiu junto onde existe um
pouco antes eu continuei mas não
aguentei muito tempo e nesse atual
escrevi um monte de poemas tanto que o
juiz não fala que eu ele acordava de
madrugada eu estava escrevendo eu estava
mudando meu jeito de escrever e eu acho
que quando a gente está vivendo uma
paixão amor nem tudo do jeito que a
gente quer né
eu tive que dar um hiato naquela minha
naquela coisa gostosa detalhe no metrô
eu estava passando por um momento
difícil ou seja a minha relação de
paixão e nesse tempo a produzir um livro
né eu achava que eu não podia lançar um
livro porque eu não era bom bastante né
eu eu falo assim puxamos um caso do mon
e quando eu custei a entender que não
precisavam ser carlos drumont em que seu
filho e piarco ligado e você não precisa
ser o seu primo que às vezes a sua
família fala assim nossa e seu primo que
já passou e mil faculdades não você é
você tá ligado você precisa escrever a
sua história ea gente né eu juntos não
temos que pensar formas de novo de
ganhar dinheiro é a gente fez outro
brainstorm ele veio com outra ideia
genial ele fala assim porque a gente não
vende paçoca cara todo mundo gosta de
paçoca
eu falei o ovo tá só que é louco todo
mundo gosta de paçoca
por exemplo aqui quem não gosta de
paçoca gil tem sempre um eu não mando
embora eu não posso
mas eu acredito na cura irmão eu
acredito
inclusive vamos combinar que a gente
pode fazer uma oração pra ele que não
gosta de paçoca me procura no final e
pronto grupo de pessoas netp quem foi
cruzeirense também dá tempo
e é isso tipo assim ele falou vamos
vender passar o que eu falei como ele
não sei a gente pensando assim a gente
descobriu que a paz só que eu tinha
diminuído de tamanho inclusive acho que
cabe um protesto na porta da prefeitura
porque passou aqui é bom demais ea gente
descobriu que ela tinha diminuído de
tamanho forma sim vão vender 5 paçoca
por um real nem aí naquela coisa vamos
vender paçoca igual ricardo eletro é
vender só que pra caramba ea gente foi
comprou duas caixas paçoca montou um uma
caixa de papelão na passarela da
lagoinha perda rodoviária e ficamos lá
ea gente esperava a pessoa passa passava
gente todo mundo olhava e ninguém
comprava e ficava e ele assim olhando
pro outro e aí a gente faz um mantra né
a pessoa passar vai ficar assim compra
compra compra compra compra compra ea
pessoa passava direta fazem aids gramado
e ninguém comprava ea gente foi
descobrindo que as pessoas os outros
camelôs gritavam né
e junto falou pô tem que gritar e falar
pois é
grita se ele gritou serra vai ser
primeiro na ce e aí eu sou muito tímido
pode não parecer mas eu falava assim
silva só com o real
as pessoas estavam q5 passado isso
morreu me dá me dá 10 mil a 5 reais e
também o povo começou a comprar passou
casas nahb com o tempo a gente foi
perdendo né ea timidez rossi gente
passou aqui vêm comprar melhor passar
pelo brasil ponte que caiu é melhor
passar cá do brasil e o povo com paçoca
e de repente começou a vender dez caixas
de paçoca e eu comecei a pensar numa
coisa porque eu estou virando passou
quero mas eu não queria ser passou que é
eu queria ser escritor tinha alguma
coisa errada eu podia tá ganhando
dinheiro vendendo paçoca mas não era
isso ou eu tinha um livro guardado eu
falei juntos só quer saber se eu vender
200 mil paróquias a gente fez um cálculo
muito louco vender 200 mil paróquias vou
lançar esse meu livro eu chamaria de 200
mil passou com as infinitas poesias e
foi de 2013 a 2015 sofrimento na rua é
batida de fiscal povo passava e ainda
estava brigado com minha mãe fala assim
rose felipe está virando um mendigo e
tal era loucura mas acabou que eu
consegui realizar esse sonho 2015
eu não sei o meu livro meu primeiro
livro 200 mil paróquias infinitas
poesias eu não eu não acreditava porque
eu virei e falei assim cara eu nunca
mais vou vender paçoca na minha vida era
o plano que eu tinha feito porque quando
o assunto é paixão amor a gente gosta
daquilo a gente faz eu nunca mais vou
fazer aquilo eu faço e nunca mais me
passou que lancei meu livro um sábado
último dia que o vento passou até sexta
o lançamento do meu livro foi um fiasco
na segunda que eu fui fazer
vender paçoca e o pensamento é o
seguinte o pensamento era o cara deu
errado achei que eu ia ficar famoso
achei que tudo ia dar certo vende 200
exemplares
eu eu queria achei que ia estourar e não
foi o meu pensamento foi o seguinte foi
assim no amor né porque já tinha virado
um amor à escrita a poesia na minha vida
já era um amor e eu entendi a maior
dádiva do amor que é tipo assim nem
sempre tudo vai dar certo mas isso não
pode te fazer desistir alegado isso mexe
comigo demais a ponto de eu saber que o
amor por exemplo se tem história da
minha mãe e às vezes cada um tem suas
histórias é eu sei dos meus defeitos eu
sei dos problemas que a gente tem mas
independente disso eu te amo eu te
perdôo eu tô com você e é isso que faz a
diferença ou não duvidei que eu daria
certo
eu o continue vendendo paçoca
posteriormente eu fiz uma viagem pelo
brasil lancei o meu segundo livro e no
lançamento do meu segundo livro só no
lançamento eu venho de 1.200 livros e aí
alguma coisa começou a acontecer dentro
de mim que eu falei eu poderia ter
parado lá no começo poxa deu errado
vamos voltar chega dessa brincadeira
chega dessa coisa de vender de tentar
ser escritor vou viver minha vida de de
jornalista você como alguém normal e vou
tentar viver uma vida medíocre não que
todo mundo que faça faculdade tem uma
vida medíocre não só que a gente se
acostuma nesse processo
hoje eu vejo isso pelo menos na minha
família nas pessoas que eu convivo as
pessoas não são felizes e lembrando do
que eu falei da criança a gente perde
essa simplicidade de ser feliz a gente
era simplesmente feliz né a gente hoje
faz planos para ser feliz a gente
assemelha a felicidade com com o passado
a gente encontra um amigo da antiga
fosse nossa como era legal aquela época
a gente era tão feliz a gente esquece de
ser feliz a gente não preocupa às vezes
a gente não tá curtindo o momento a
gente quer que acabe por filipe está
falando de um tempão que era que vai
acabar
ai minha faculdade que era que vai
a minha vida que era que vai acabar sabe
em 12 meses hoje dia hoje é dia 31 de
agosto de 2009 e 31 de agosto de 2018
foram 12 meses
a gente dormiu basicamente um ser humano
normal quatro meses
quem trabalha também trabalhou quatro
meses e ainda tem o tempo você fica no
ônibus e pode colocar mais um mês se
contar tudo e ainda tem um tempo que de
quem faz faculdade mas de dois meses o
tempo de diversão que ainda sobra sefaz
imposto agora vou aproveitar vou dormir
o dia inteiro ea gente vai vivendo essa
vida e se a gente não acha prazer nessas
pequenas coisas que a gente não acha
paixão nosso trabalho se a gente não
acha paixão a nossa vida se eu chego na
minha sala
na minha casa e eu sou a pessoa que não
muda que não transforma que não faz
diferença para que eu estou vivendo o
que está acontecendo na minha vida saber
se o questionamento que eu sempre fiz eu
acho que a gente não pode perder essa
simplicidade essa coisa de ser feliz e
eu encontrei nisso apesar das
dificuldades hoje ainda não foi
estabelecido um aceno passado o meu
terceiro livro a menina do vestido azul
né e esse ano daqui a alguns dias
avançar o meu quarto livro para cada
momento da vida e hoje eu vivo
unicamente do meu trabalho eu tenho
várias fontes de renda e eu consigo
transformar vidas e eu acabei entendendo
que é um ciclo nef fazer o que ama
ajudar pessoas e consequentemente ganhar
dinheiro qualquer coisa que seja fora
desse ciclo de errado
a coisa que mais pode fazer alguém feliz
é isso fazer o que ama ajudar pessoas e
consequentemente ganhar uma grana com
isso porque a gente também é filho de
deus merece uma conta cheia
a verdade é que de tudo isso eu escrevi
um verso que ele marca minha vida até
hoje eu queria deixar pra vocês que é
estrelas nascem do caos e ainda assim
tem a missão de iluminar o universo quer
dizer que a gente pode estar passando o
problema que for a dificuldade que for
nunca esqueça que você tem que iluminar
vidas
tá muito obrigado
[Aplausos]
[Música]